Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the top 50 devilish
details you missed in Lucifer's final season,
from ingenious easter eggs and call-backs
to hilarious meta references and hidden jokes.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Since she first stole the hearts of Lucifans
in the pilot,
My name's Beatrice, but everybody calls me
Trixie.
That's a hooker's name.
What's a hooker?
Ask your mother.
Scarlett Estevez has gifted us some wonderful
scenes, and there's some fun easter eggs at
Maze's wedding to memorable moments between
her and Trixie.
So when Maze walks down the aisle, as she
reaches her little friend they do a fist bump
then their signature cut-throat sign which
we saw a longer version of in the third season
episode Mr and Mrs Mazikeen Smith.
Later at the reception, as Adam and Dr Linda
walk into the scene, watch the background
very carefully as while Eve is enjoying a
glass of something sparkly, Maze is pouring
something a little stronger;
after which she checks around and surreptitiously
tries to pass the glass of hard liquor to
Trixie!
Until, that is, Eve realizes what her new
wife's up to and stops her!
But this isn't the first time that Maze has
offered Trixie an alcoholic drink, as she
also did that as a bartender at Lux in Season
1.
Is this a Shirley Temple?
Sure.
Check out the pile of presents at the reception,
and among the boxes you'll spot a spiky gift
with a festive white bow attached!
As one of Hell's foremost torturers, Mazikeen
certainly knows her weaponry, and will doubtless
appreciate this addition to her collection
especially as this particular weapon is called
a morning star.
Of course, it's at the wedding that Ella reveals
she knows her friends' celestial secret.
And for Lucifans, the apocalypse board she
created to work it all out is the gift that
just keeps giving for Lucifans!
For example, there's her theories about what
caused Dan the frog to fall from the sky,
which include whether it's some kind of weird
side effect from Detective Dan's favourite
dessert.
The red eyes post-it note on Luci's photo
is a nod to his devil eyes which he used briefly
in Season 3 on Ella's brother, who could well
have told her at some point likely leading
her to this clue.
And proving what a great detective mind she
has, we can see she figured out everyone's
secret including Charlie being half angel
and Maze a demon.
That picture of Maze by the way is from the
hilarious time in Season 5 she dressed up
and tried to imitate Ella to make herself
more emotionally available.
Oh, my God, I have that exact same shirt!
Yes, you did!
Wait.
Did you steal my clothes?
As for Dan, it seems Ella briefly entertained
ideas that he was also a supernatural creature
like a werewolf, vampire or centaur but ended
up dismissing them.
Funny for many reasons including that actor
Kevin Alejandro starred in the vampire TV
show True Blood;
and also Goddess, who Dan dated, has centaurs
in her new universe!
The feather in the bag is a reference to the
Season 5 finale where the writers had some
fun with us making it seem Ella was about
to discover the truth:
I think I know what this is about, Lucifer.
You, you do?
So tell me the truth.
You hit an emu with your car, didn't you?
By the way, fun fact:
when Season 5 was going to be the final season,
the plan was for Ella to discover the truth
right at the very end in the closing montage
where she was babysitting Charlie and he sprouted
wings.
And I love that, along with the many wild
headlines and apocalyptic Post-It Notes, Ella's
also written what looks like a rather more
mundane reminder to herself:
"Did you turn off stove?"
Lucifer's eclectic To-Do List is a funny insight
into his mind.
He's already decided against becoming God
and manages to bond with his daughter Rory,
and up there next is checking in on Father
Frank from the Season 1 fan favourite episode,
A Priest Walks Into A Bar.
It makes sense Luci would want to visit him
in Heaven and see what he's up to, given how
hard he took his death.
Father Frank was one of the few people to
realise that Lucifer was actually the Devil
and he reminded Luci that God had not abandoned
him:
You're wrong, Lucifer.
Remember...
your father...
has-has a plan.
It's also hard not to chuckle at Luci's idea
to mess with Dan by naming him after Casper
the Friendly Ghost as well as his plan to
rewatch all twelve seasons of Bones, that's
246 episodes, thank you very much!
That show was the perfect combination of procedure
and banter.
As for São Paolo's inclusion on the list,
that might be a reference to the real-life
serial killer imprisoned in the Brazilian
city who calls himself Lucifer and has apparently
killed many other prison inmates he views
as bad people.
Perhaps Luci intends to put a stop to someone
using his name for their own ends, as he did
with Luci-phony, the Lucifer impersonator
from Season 1.
I'm Lucifer freaking Morningstar!
Oh...
Are you now?
we can't have you running around cheapening
the Lucifer brand, now, can we?
Because, as we know, one thing Lucifer hates
in particular is being used as a scapegoat
for the bad and evil choices human beings
make by themselves.
The Devil made me do it.
I have never made any one of them do anything.
And, of course, given this is Lucifer's list
there's a final reference to a new sexual
position he wants to try out.
A billboard for the TV series ¡Diablo! based
on Lucifer's original Season 1 poster pops
up in the episode 'Buckets of Baggage'.
And that ad first appeared during a magnificently
meta Season 5 murder investigation.
You want to find the killer, figure out their
yearning.
Isn't there a better word for that?
And interestingly enough, the deliberate choice
to insert the ¡Diablo! billboard into this
particular aerial shot of Sunset Boulevard
means it's juxtaposed with a real-life Catholic
billboard that plays on both the US "Got Milk?"
campaign and the Biblical miracle of water
being turned into wine.
And also in this shot is a real-life strip
club whose name, "Seventh Veil", is a nod
to the Dance of the Seven Veils performed
by Salomé to get King Herod to execute John
the Baptist.
When Lucifer ponders what to wear to visit
Jimmy Barnes...
Now which do you prefer?
The iconic white or pomegranate for more of
an "original sin" vibe?
...he seems to confirm the theory of some
scholars that pomegranates, not apples, were
the fruit that tempted Adam and Eve in the
Garden of Eden.
The red seeded fruit has been a running theme
in the show appearing prominently in paintings
at Charlotte the Goddess's law office and
getting a shout-out as one of original God's
mysterious creations.
He does inexplicable things from time to time.
Marsupials, pomegranates, the gall bladder.
And during Lucifer's investigation of Jimmy's
Hell Loop,
they take a period tour back to the 80s where
playing at the movie theatre is "Althea: Queen
of the Quarks", one of Penelope Decker's best-known
movies.
Posters for the film have appeared previously
on the show and it was also mentioned in Season
5.
Miss Decker, I'm a huge fan.
Althea: Queen of the Quarks, that should have
won you an Oscar.
While Chloe's mum doesn't appear in the final
season, Luci mentions that Trixie's staying
with her in the opening episode:
Grandma Penelope's heart's grown three times
the size thanks to her time with Trixie.
That's a reference to The Grinch, whose heart
triples in size after he learns the true meaning
of Christmas in particular thanks to a little
girl called Cindy Lou Who.
And it's also a nod to Scarlett Estevez, who
plays Trixie, and her role in Illumination's
animated Grinch movie as one of Cindy Lou's
friends.
There are several hat-tips this season to
the 1990s romantic thriller Ghost, from Maze's
reaction to ghost-Dan asking her to give Ella
a message:
No, I did not traipse over here on my wedding
night to be your Whoopi Goldberg.
...to Luci and Chloe's Unchained Melody moment
in the panic room.
And there's even a cameo from Patrick Swayze's
brother Don who pops up as a gas station owner
during Luci's search for his daughter.
Hat-tip to Raghu for pointing that out on
my last video!
When the Morningstar family ends up on Dr
Linda's couch with a case of future child
angst, the symmetry of Lucifer and Rory's
body language not only reflects how much they
have in common,
She takes after you in her exits.
but it also mirrors the Season 5 scene where
Luci and God had their own therapy session
with the good doctor.
Speaking of similarities, both Rory and God
also seem less than impressed with Luci's
large alcohol collection:
nothing is ever good enough for you.
Why's your kitchen just a wall of Scotch?
An entire wall of liquor upstairs and it's
all just whiskey?
And both Luci and Rory's Devil Faces pop up
when their respective fathers are under threat.
Plus, they also have very similar tastes in
TV!
the best TV show you have ever seen.
Bones.
The spin-off from my time kicks your Bones'
ass.
More Bones is the perfect combination of procedure
and banter.
So, in many ways the apple really hasn't fallen
far from the tree!
Luci's love affair with Bones actually began
back in Season 3:
Watched all 12 seasons.
It's riveting stuff.
It's like watching a documentary of us.
And in Season 6, he's still not over it getting
the chop at Fox, the same channel that also
cancelled Lucifer!
this is a terrible idea.
Worst I've heard since some genius decided
to cancel Bones.
In fact, in episode 5, Luci thinks he disappears
from Rory's life due to death by dentist as
Dr Kyle seems strangely familiar to him.
But then he realises why:
Do these commercials ever run during Bones?
Syndicated audiences are tooth decay audiences.
Which reminds me of another time when Luci's
Bones obsession led him astray in Season 3:
Detective, I've seen that man before.
He's the killer.
That man turned out to be an actor from Bones
in both real life and in Lucifer!
On top of all those tributes to the former
Fox show, Bones actress Patricia Belcher also
guest stars in Season 6 as Loretta.
I love the song choice of 'Worship' by the
artist LACES for Eve and Maze's wedding, and
the way that episode's editor has cut the
action to the song lyrics is just fantastic,
as it gives us moments like the camera focusing
on Lucifer and Chloe as the words 'maybe in
another life' ring out, foreshadowing their
separation by the end of the show and their
eventual reunion in Hell.
Then there's the shot of Maze with the lyrics
'Cause Heaven won't take me';
then we cut to Eve on the line 'Devil won't
take me', which certainly fits her Season
4 experience with Lucifer;
then we move to Luci and Chloe again as LACES
sings 'Nothing feels better than you'; before
cutting to ghost-Dan, followed by Amenadiel,
on the line 'If angels won't save me'.
Given Eve's Garden of Eden origins, it feels
especially appropriate that she and Maze are
married in front of a large tree and a pair
of flower-covered rings, in their own little
paradise of sorts.
The real-life location for the wedding is
the lush garden of the Walt Disney Concert
Hall in LA,
which seems extra fitting as Inbar Lavi plays
the original sinner Eve with all the excitement
and innocent wonder of a Disney princess with
an added naughty side.
The garden theme continues at the reception,
with Maze and Eve sitting in front of a heart-shaped
tree covered in pinky red fairy lights, a
colour associated with both love and the devil,
and it also reminds me of classic images of
the Tree of Knowledge.
Another delightful little detail, you could
say even that it's the icing on the cake,
is the cake topper which is actually a mini-version
of Eve and Maze, dressed in the very same
outfits they got married in!
Maze's choice of gifts for kids has certainly
stayed consistent over the seasons, with new-born
Rory getting a cutting-edge present from the
demon, just as baby Charlie and Trixie did
in Season 4.
Maze, you know she's not allowed to play with
knives.
Relax, Dan, these knives aren't for Trixie.
They're for a baby.
And talking of Charlie, at his birthday party,
there's a big present wrapped in serpent-covered
paper, a hint perhaps that it's from his uncle
Lucifer.
And Charlie getting his wings on his second
birthday fits nicely with the fact he's entering
the "Terrible Twos",
the period of development when toddlers often
experience temper tantrums as they test their
boundaries and want greater independence.
While Amenadiel's pleased as punch, Linda
looks shocked, as after all he'd told her
in Season 5 their son wouldn't be getting
wings at all.
Do you not realize that this is good news?
No more ugly-ass bubble wrap.
No more worrying about a head-on with a 737.
And at the polar opposite end of the gift-giving
spectrum to Maze is Ella.
And what else would you expect as a present
from Miss Lopez than something you could give
a nice big old hug to, like a teddy bear.
There is, of course, a lot more to discuss
about that ending and whether it was a good
way to finish the series which I go into in
full detail in my ending explained video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
So, what were your favourite moments in the
final season?
And what other details or easter eggs did
you spot?
Let me know in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up
and a share are hugely appreciated.
Tap left to check out my next Lucifer video
or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!